i think he is the most consistent player
in the world i think he
is the rock of the team he plays for
because he is ever
dependable taps it goes quick cool zero
is quicker
gets a second as well as the ball will
go down and follows it up
they're all lining up cold zero with an
ace he's a very well-rounded complete
player now one more to go he's gonna go
for nitro in the bullet
he keeps his cool just just a monster
coldzera finds the headshot
unbelievable relentless in his pursuit
for more kills
oh my god able to see through because it
looked like snacks was ready for him to
walk in what the hell was that from cole
great place to watch great players to
learn from as well and he's only 23
years old which is kind of ridiculous
skadoodle turns back holds here oh what
a transfer though
that doesn't have to fly over towards
the plateau
tons of trades coming in here wow zero
knows all the
angles goodbye mixwell sit down
to me he's the brazilian terminator
his team a third map here he's a genius
though he knows he can do this
losing is not an option oh coldzera is
an animal isn't he
sick shot taz is going to be going down
cole is so
hungry right now he's the shot there on
towards the wheel but it's a hell of a
shot to android
now it's a one versus whoa wow okay gold
error holding the eight he's gonna have
to flick up and he gets it
that is so fast and a second one dennis
is spamming up through the bench
leaving coldzera in a one-on-four
there's the first
looking for a snack and he connects him
oh and he gets a third as well
surely he's not gonna pull this one off
oh caldera
the man the myth the beast what is
it going on right now how does he do
this call to save
[Music]
marcelo coldzera david is one of the
best counter-strike global offensive
players
to ever live but before luminosity
gaming's fur
recruited him to help his brazilian team
reached the top
of the cs go world coldzera was a
student of the game
colt's brother rafael taught him how to
play counter-strike early on in the
competitive scenes development
rafael's friends would tease cold about
not being very good
[Music]
gaming was a huge part of colt's life
but he had to hide it from his parents
who feared his relationship with the
game
had gone too far cold's father started a
broom manufacturing company out of his
garage that had expanded and become the
family business
that cold was expected to take over and
initially his father forbade him from
leaving brazil
to compete with luminosity in north
america but
one phone call from fallen the godfather
of brazilian counter-strike
changed everything
[Music]
[Music]
around
[Music]
with his father's blessing the young
rifler was finally off to the united
states
early in 2015 lumenocity was climbing
the ranks of the counter-strike world
faster than any brazilian team in the
game's history and when coldzera joined
the team in july they finally secured
the firepower they needed to compete
with the best
coldzera's land debut with luminosity
would come at esl one cologne 2015.
of course we are looking at luminosity
their roster for you fallen steel fur
bolt and the new man coldzera as he's
going to be kind of being that new
factor for them intrigued to see how
much he can do and i mean for me he's
the unknown factor for both us but also
for his opponents
despite coming into the event with
little expected of them
luminosity fought their way out of
groups holland's gonna be
stuck in the corner but he can fight his
way out of this we've seen it before
we've seen it
happen time and time again but it's cold
three kills back to back he doesn't need
to get the other because let's bear in
mind there's three players still
standing in his steel
and that is a brilliant half coming in
for luminosity made it there
the bomb could go down any second but
blade is not done
he wants his team to make it further but
no fallen and fur
do what's required and now just out cost
alive is luminosity
one kill away but there it is fur just
pins dab costs down
and luminosity after such a tough route
after such a tough game finally make it
through
but in the quarterfinals they found
themselves matched up against the
tournament favorites
fnatic while luminosity pushed the
european juggernaut to their limit
fnatic ultimately proved to be too great
of an obstacle for the brazilians to
overcome just needs to
give himself a moment a breather oh
that's the shot he needed to land they
know his position they're gonna try and
brush him down
he needs to switch to pistol they're
gonna get him finally well taken
they will get a defuse his 16-14 fanatic
they move through
to face vertis pro in the semi-finals
well we have to say that
luminosity they should go home with
heads held high and
a a very good outlook for the future
over the next few months coldzera
settled into luminosity and began to
show
exactly why fallen had been set on him
joining the team
really sick angle here and he's just
popped her out straight away there's two
more players on the bomb side itself
so with the boost here luminosity
they're actually looking fantastic
they're going to send the top frag a
cold straight and he's going to take
down freaking sword as well they don't
even know what's hitting them at this
point switches to the sea said
completely annihilates nothing and the
defuse can come in here now skadoodle is
being handled by steel
and that was absolutely beautiful 4k
from cold i think he's on 23 kills right
now this guy is having
a mental first half cold widely regarded
as uh probably the best player coming
out of brazil right now
it often shuts itself down but cole does
find these bombs going to approach from
the same angle up past catwalk
and cold spores back to the ct spawn so
they will get this bomb plant left in a
two on two
and they picked up the famas on guardian
as well is that going to be enough to
push it over the end cool great job
scott never mind they've
lost down already as he hits them from
elevator and they know edward's out
toward long so as sex
they're putting the last player in that
position to try and push through the
long doors edward does two damage on the
cold
oh he ain't falling what a brilliant
shot and it's one hp but cold
even better with the mp7 how
many jump shots did he get in one round
of the mp7 one
one short one on the bomb site and
finishes the player off from the fit as
well that's absolutely amazing from cold
tower what a game does this be
going down to a five on three situation
manages to pull it off as well
while luminosity would be knocked out in
the quarterfinals of dreamhack
cluj-napoca
it was undeniable that the team had made
significant strides in 2015.
however it was clear that they needed
some extra star power to pair with
coldzera
if they were to contend for a major
title so prior to dreamhack leipzig
taco and fnx were brought in with fallen
as their primary offer
cold their secondary op and primary
fragger and
taco fnx and fur's added fragging power
the classic
luminosity lineup we've come to know
today had assembled
and they took the tournament by storm as
you know like how long it's gonna take
him
nice spray down from cold though cold is
close he's got fnx there and now fallen
showing up with the awp
as the danes trying to make one last
attempt to actually extend this game
good and shot from
fnx but they've already lost one if next
getting a second one bomb has gone down
with this oh they line up after that
he gets four kills and now pimp is left
could it be another ace in this
one game for fnx that would be nuts pip
is looking for an fnx he gets
round might be losing more members than
they want to but
look at this call actually dodging the
monotone goes for the kill he gets it on
michael
and then it could get really ugly coal
coming around the corner he shots down
ac
and now it's on jacob he's very low on
health that bomb they can still defuse
it even without the kid right now jacob
he's going to go for it he's got to be
careful getting shot in the back any
second and he goes down and that defuse
already happening oh
no 14 seconds that bomb are not coming
through they go for the boost
and sip is going to be gone now it's all
cajun he fakes it once go for the three
it's gonna go down
and there it is luminosity 2-0 versus
astralis
luminosity made it all the way to the
grand finals
where again they would face navi in a
close series he's
making his way around the train trying
to see if he can maybe catch out fallen
he's not got the hell for it fallen has
to shot immediately he's trying to
predict it seized
is he gonna see it falling oh there's
the shot he gets all three kills
he's there to back him and edward he's
gonna cancel pushing through the smoke
this is it navi's moment
oh cold getting a kill on flame he had
we're going through and he's gonna get
that spray down
taco alone in a one versus three comes
charging through what else can he do
he goes down navi they win train 1916.
to taco the man who annihilated guardian
and there you go flamie gets the timing
right he gets the second one as well
and now the last man is on the plateau
this is it the moment for navi
can they actually lock it out there's
the spray flamey with the triple
and navi will be the dreamhack leipzig
champions
in the end navi would prevail and while
luminosity were disappointed to have
lost
their impressive performance signaled
better things to come
individually cold had played like a man
possessed and it was clear that the team
would be contenders at the upcoming
columbus major
and contend they did lg swept both
mousesports and ninjas and pajamas in
the group stage to make it to the top
eight
once they got to the bracket stage it
was coldzera's time to prove himself
against the best in the world but after
bringing their quarterfinal opponent
virtus pro
to match point on cash luminosity began
to falter
for a really fast execute here snacks on
the other side flashbang goes up they're
gonna be all around the corner he's got
the egg but this is very open position
he sprays down one of the second two
finally the reply but neil is there
getting a double of his own and they
will lock luminosity out of this round
what a mad position it's gonna be pasha
taking down
fallen that means that means to end up
winning it they're really learning from
the mistakes
oh what a shock cold sarah trying to
duck in behind that box
and snatch just catching him mid-air
water performance on the polish team
they definitely were in a slump but now
they seem to have somehow rooted
themselves out of it there's their
headshot versus throw they win cash 19
17. coldzera and luminosity found
themselves down a map
and facing another premature tournament
departure
but this time the brazilians were up for
the task so now they need to get off of
it and cold he smokes himself
out of position and so now they actually
have no way of dealing with him he needs
to make a mistake and overstep himself
he's just called the size in the back
line peaks out of the perfect time gonna
be able to kill
taz very low on health and in a 105
can't even get the kill
fourth round is a flawless one here for
the brazilian side
still not looking too hot here for first
pro i mean at least by ali gets a kill
but
called that's a sick shot taz is going
to be going down cole is so hungry right
now he's going to get the third as well
he has absolutely no fear or no respect
for murders pro there he just takes all
the peaks
14 zero and three with cold series
absolutely mad carrying the brazilian
side
sneaking up he's got a good position
he's making it out as well but he goes
down
cold sarah is there it's gone horribly
wrong hasn't it
it is gonna be 9-3 here and called cyra
picking up neo it's all on tas and
there's nothing that he can really do at
this point paul just on the hunt
getting the double kill making it 10-3
playing it against the vp
pasha going down another double sierra
looking for a bit more
it's going to be fnx to steal that kill
called an fnx top fragging
everything riding on taco here they
almost lined up he gets the one spree in
turns around for it second kill and
there it is the grenades
has gone and luminosity are in the semis
of a major tournament
after coming back to take two straight
maps off one of the best teams in the
world
luminosity moved on to face team liquid
in the semi-finals
liquid were looking to make cs go
history by becoming the first n a major
champs
with a star-studded lineup of their own
and at first
the brazilian squad looked over-matched
this is not the luminosity
who won the hearts of fans over the
recent weeks and months this is
this is a ghost i mean what about
what we saw on the a bombsite there i
guess i guess that's that's
lost that round that runs over there
look at this simple double fallen and
cold
they need the big guns to come out big
pressure
on the big players of luminosity but can
they deliver the big result that they
need to stay here
but when luminosity needed it most cold
put the team on his back with what will
go down
as one of the most memorable plays in cs
go's
storied history here he comes once again
the first base is a trend he's going to
hit the ground there's paul
wow that's jumping double for code what
is
it going on right now how does he do
this come on to save luminosity with the
all play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments they needed a huge play but
that was something i'm never gonna see
ever again i have no words to describe
oh my holy
okay a lot has been said about the
probability of landing a shot like this
a double headshot with the op while
leaping
but what can't be overlooked is that he
landed it when his team had their backs
against the wall
in the semi-finals of a major and it
completely changed the momentum of the
series
he's the man you want in this position
but one versus three
this is for everything this is for the
map right now hiko making its way
around the smoke this family will spot
taco but that's it luminosity with a
comeback from 1510
an amazing play from cole with the awp
all the way back into overtime into a
victory off the back of cold's
spectacular play
luminosity cast aside both liquid and
their history of top 8 busts
earning a shot at redemption against
na'vi in another grand final
this time they made quick work of the
ukrainian powerhouse to become the first
non-european team to ever win a major
and now it is a one-on-two taco looking
to see if he could close it out here and
win it
for the brazilians it's gonna be a big
turn around there hits the headshot on
susan now it's a one-on-one
guardian versus taco it may just be
destined to be and it's luminosity
winning their first
major championship that win was not only
huge for the brazilian squad
but for the entire cs world as well it
was now clear that it was possible to
confront the european gods of
counter-strike at the major level and
come out unscathed
and it came as no surprise to anyone
when coldzera was named the tournament's
mvp
we're only talking about like six or
seven months and this guy is now in the
position to be the mvp of a world
championship tournament they really have
built the game off his back in terms of
fragging prior to columbus
luminosity were certainly on a hot
streak but this win
placed them among the top teams in the
world and etched their names into cs
history
over the next few months the team went
on to win four consecutive lan events
including wins at both dreamhack austin
and the esl pro league season 3 finals
luminosity's next shot at a major
championship would be at esl one cologne
but while they should have been focused
on winning back-to-back majors
the team was dealing with distractions
outside of the game
just days before the columbus major
luminosity's roster and coaching staff
had signed contracts to move from
luminosity to
sk gaming but the teams started to
regret their decision
after winning in columbus and were
locked into a back and forth
between the two organizations the news
that coldzera and his teammates were in
the midst of a contractual dispute
dominated headlines even with esl one
cologne around the corner
the problem is the stress of all this
[ __ ] that's gone on
and people may be looking down on them
or they themselves being conflicted if
they didn't necessarily want things to
work out this way
that's what concerns me because i don't
want to see them now be under so much
pressure because of that that they tilt
away the next major
after the dust had finally settled
coldzera and company walked into the lan
access arena
under the sk gaming banner sk kicked off
the tournament by beating both faze clan
and g2 esports in the group stage
before dispatching flip side tactics and
virtus pro
in the quarter and semi-finals flash on
cold zero that actually was miss thrown
from his teammate but there it is tacos
closed it
and that's k the defending champions
will return to the finals
the stage was set for sk to meet team
liquid in the grand finals
marking the first time that two
non-european teams
competed for a major title and with
simple and coldzera both playing
outstanding cs
it was set to be a grand final to
remember
this round was a sure thing but they
slowed down i think they even failed the
molotov
good kill from cold zero but still only
28 seconds here they need to move in and
get this ball plant home
ahiko i don't think anyone has even seen
him they don't know where he is right
now
a lot of damage being put into cold
sierra as well 19
seconds and now finally sk are going to
man up and try and see if they can get
out here hiko picking up a kill and it's
all down to cold zero
10 seconds jumping back onto the side he
has to stick the plant he can't even
fake it and actually he's going to be
successful in that
now the deagle goes for the fight takes
out nico and now it's a one-on-one or
versus all but jdm goes down
go zero that's the core kill and sk
gonna pick up a very very tight round
called sierra is going to realize wait i
mean if they're all coming down ivy he's
looking the exact perfect spot
takes one takes two and a third one
coming through as well and he's gonna be
going down
cole sierra eating every single member
of liquid coming through
the back lines and now it's a two on two
and make that a one on two
jdm entirely alone here trying to see if
he can hold on to it
taco and cold zera still alive on the
other side and
liquid haven't won many of these clutch
rounds but this time they're going to
have to otherwise sk are going to be
back into it of course
called sierra picking up the kill he's
at 11 overall
makes a lot of sense simple now alone on
the side backup is coming and taco
being caught in an uncomfortable
position ends up going down oh ready and
waiting
and no kind of backup possible here hiko
gotta fall as well
it is match and map and tournament point
here for
sk now it's just all in the details
easy for sk to pick it up here trying to
walk through the smoke but it's just not
gonna happen sk gaming
second major championship in a row they
are your winners
they were the best team in the world and
coldzera
once again the mvp of the tournament was
the undisputed king
of counter strike fallen coldzera and
the rest of sk gaming
did what once felt impossible they built
a team from the ground up
and they made their game work and now it
wasn't vertice pro
fnatic or navi who were the team to beat
heading into 2017.
it was five brazilian players the sk
era is officially here but even as they
stood atop the counter-strike world
sk gaming were not immune to conflict
outside of the game
just prior to the beginning of the 2017
season
the team kicked fnx rumor swirled that
he was removed because of internal
issues
but all that most cs go fans saw was
that sk's two major winning core
was now without one of its top
performers fox
stepped in to take fnx's place just in
time for the eleague major in atlanta
but the pressure fell on coldzera to
remind everyone
who the tournament favorites were he's
well out of position but at least
he knows a hundred percent that colt has
to be on the bombsite planting the bomb
right now
and so will he realize oh god not out
but he realizes that
cold was close enough to take the
engagement holding the angle
just creeping who's gonna be first to
get the first bullets off it's gonna be
cole who takes the kill
imports an incredibly crucial round one
of those already been used and
the other one is never gonna be thrown
by zero so sticko and dead fox now just
damn fox left
trying his best he's going to get the
headshot at least so a bit of a smile
for him steals an ak i don't think he's
going to get to keep it through this
round
is coming for him don't see them coming
back from this one sk the bomb is down
but
the wreath oh what cold sarah
right for the smoke while sk's quest for
a third consecutive major title would
ultimately end at the hands of virtus
pro
it hadn't stopped cold from showing why
he was the best player in the world
in the wake of atlanta the team brought
in phelps as the long-term replacement
for fnx
and they regained their form heading
into the pgl major
in krakow at the event sk went 3-1
through the group stage and found
themselves in the top 8
of yet another major but this time sk
gaming were
ousted by astralis in the quarterfinals
it's a two versus five to try and k sk
gaming alive
in this tournament or put astralis right
in the semi-final and cold zero and
fortune
trying to see if they can coordinate
this the grenades are coming in this 30
seconds
and they're boxing they can't even go
back here falling once a peak from
somebody anybody there's device
he gets one still a two on four and
there's 20 seconds
now following this alone in a one versus
four he's going to get one more kill but
there's only 17
seconds he can't get this bomb part down
astralis will have done it
they're in the semi-final 16-6 the
disappointing exit marked the first time
that the brazilian squad had missed out
on a top four appearance
since columbus in 2016. by the end of
2017
sk gaming and colezera had a lot to
reflect on
toward the end of the year the world of
cs was in flux
the game was trending towards super
teams and organizations were looking to
surround their stars with the best
talent in the hopes of racking up major
titles
it was time to see if sk's lineup could
keep up in this new era
and at esl pro league season 6 finals sk
gaming proved
that they could still hang with the
scenes best
but kerrigan styles the kill they're
gonna get on this immediately as well
kerrigan has one of the kids
cool he's held off from four they've
gotta get to kerrigan now or they just
barely have done it fallen gets the kill
gold was there
goes back out and finds olaf in the
one-on-one down to guardian again to
save them he goes aggressive
hits taco he still has a slight chance a
smoke deployed by the terrorists
actually gives him a chance to funnel in
but bolt says no and sk
in three sk were no longer the
untouchable team that the community
thought they were
in 2016. but on the big stage coldzera
slammed the door
shut on rising claims that nico had
surpassed him
as csgo's apex predator he's planted
potentially for him and they're not
really sure which position he's going to
win
he's found the diffuser as well it's
kerrigan down nico's got a kit but he's
got to contend with the fact that cold
now has the advantage they're both mid
30s on hp
and cold is going to change it to get
the head shot and close it in fashion
[Applause]
if you wanted a duel between nico and
cold you got it and cold comes out on
top
as 2018 began the e-league boston major
was the next chance for sk
to reclaim their title as the preeminent
team in cs go
but unfortunately for coldzera sk would
not make history again
instead the brazilians would become a
footnote in cloud9's own historic
achievement
as the first ever american team to win a
major
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds
and cloud9 are in the grand finals of a
major tournament
nobody saw this coming sk brought the
same core lineup that had worked for
them forever but this time
it simply wasn't good enough
since the major sk gaming have looked
worse than they ever have
with the team having undergone yet
another roster transition
but as question marks surround sk gaming
for the first time in years
coldzera remains unquestionable he was
ranked the top player in the world
for the second straight year by hltv in
2017
and even as sk has faltered at the start
of 2018
he's still shown that he is superhuman
coldzera
who else he is left in the clutch norm
v3
with a mission but is it mission
impossible
i'm about to find out making his way oh
that's a snap and a half hold again
oh cole gets himself another one uh to
get him to plant towards
connector oh he's selling a trap called
zero he's on the bomb now holding it
two seconds one second with a ridiculous
clutch
and he's like come on man try me do you
know who i am
there's no doubt that esports move fast
a team or player can go from best in the
world
to mediocre in months but so far in his
career
coldzera is one of a handful of
counter-strike players
ever that always shows up from the
moment his father got off the phone with
fallen
coldzera has been stalking his prey
he's got gold walking in next point
oh my goodness dropping jaws with
displays of unbelievable skill
last time this happened it was cut way
too close oh
what producing awe-inspiring clutches
when his team is behind all down to cold
zera
14 hp but forget that because it is
cold zero he tries to get the shot out
he's gonna picture he's got a leash
low hp's he goes back in with the off
and that is why cole is the best in the
world
a generational talent willing to make
sacrifices
to win championships the sk era is
officially here
one of the most complete and consistent
players
counter-strike has ever seen here he
comes once again the first base is a
trend he's going to hit the ground there
is cold oh
wow that's jumping double from cold what
is it going on right now
how does he do this no drama no trash
talk
and no complications just kill after
kill he's the best player in the world
james
that's who he is thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this
be sure to hit the subscribe button